PROFESSOR: All
right before we get
started, I just
wanted to say goodbye
to Eric Joisel, who
died on Sunday, sadly.
He's a master origami creator,
and I encourage you all
to come see "Between
the Folds" on Tuesday,
showing Tuesday
evening, because there's
a great interview with him, and
it really captures his spirit.
And sadly, I never
met him in person.
The last I corresponded with
him was to get permission
to show these photos in class.
So that sucks.
Today is about rigidity again.
And in particular, something
called infinitesimal rigidity.
So last class was mostly
about generic rigidity.
Today we're going to
talk about a variation,
although related to
generic rigidity.
And this is going to
be a very useful tool.
It's a lot easier to work
with algorithmically.
It still captures
essentially generic rigidity,
but in a different
way-- in a linear way.
And it's going to
be super useful.
So the idea is we think about
rigidity-- does a linkage
move or not-- to
the first order.
First order means
first derivative.
OK, so I'm going to do some
analysis stuff-- calculus,
which you should all know,
because is the General
Institute Requirement.
Don't worry, you don't
need to know much.
So in particular
rigidity, is really
about the lack of motion.
So let's define the idea
of infinitesimal motion,
or first-order motion.
This is, again, suppose
we start somewhere.
And somewhere would be
a linkage configuration.
There's a linkage.
There's a graph,
with edge lengths
plus configuration maps
every vertex to a point.
I'm going to assume we're
working in the plane for now.
But really this works in--
I'll say d dimensions.
So this is what
I want to define.
I'm going to say that
it is a valid-- this
is sort of an informal notion--
a valid first derivative
of a motion.
We've already defined motions.
I want to take such a
motion, essentially,
take its derivative
with respect to time,
And evaluate that
derivative at time 0.
This is a fancy way of saying
the following picture-- I'd
like a motion, which is some
path in the configuration
space-- remember,
configuration space
is some hugely
dimensional object,
d n dimensions-- and
a point in that space
corresponds to a configuration.
We have a motion is
some path in that space.
And motions are
hard to think about.
They can be really complicated.
So I just want to say, well,
how do you get started moving?
What direction do you
go in in a linear sense,
to the first order?
What's the derivative?
What's the tangent
right at the beginning?
And then this
notion will, stated
in terms of motions--
you can think
about this in the
absence of a motion.
Say, well, yeah, I don't really
know whether this curve exists,
but let's just see, does this
initial starting direction
exist?
And that's actually a little
weaker than the whole motion
existing.
If the motion exists, surely
you can take this derivative
and evaluate it.
It's not totally
obvious, but it's true.
You need some smoothness.
But if there's a way
to get started moving,
that doesn't actually mean
you could actually move.
Why don't I give a more formal
definition, and a more useful
one-- but that's the intuition.
So another way to think
of an infinitesimal motion
is, instead of saying how each
vertex moves in d dimensions,
you just give a velocity
vector for each vertex.
For every vertex v, we're going
to get some velocity vector
d of v-- that's direction
or derivative of v.
And with motions,
we were supposed
to preserve edge lengths.
So here we'd like to
preserve edge lengths,
but that's actually
kind of hard to do.
If you take an edge--
so I have two vertices,
and I assign some velocity
vectors, something like this--
as soon as you move a little
bit in that direction,
the edge length won't
be quite the same.
But it'll be the same
to the first order,
so this is going to
be a little subtle.
And in the book, we
take the derivatives.
We work out all the details.
But I'll just tell you
what the condition is,
because ultimately all we
need is this condition.
I'm just defining an
infinitesimal motion
to be a velocity vector
for every vertex,
such that this property holds.
This is a dot product
between two vectors.
If you have two vectors, a and
b, you take their dot product,
this is just
something like this.
You take the x-coordinates.
You multiply them together.
You take the y-coordinates.
You multiply them
together, and so on.
Add them up.
And we're going to need
some linear algebra.
That's one useful
linearity thing.
So these are where
the configuration
places vertex v and vertex w.
So this should be true for
each edge v w on the graph.
This is a vector C
of v minus C of w.
Let me give some labels.
Let's say this is
w, and this is v.
Let's say these are the points
that the configuration places
w and v at.
Then C of v minus C
of w is this vector.
It's a vector.
It doesn't really
have any space.
It's just been
translated around.
It's a vector that
would point from w
to v in the configuration.
That's the left part.
The right part has no
real intuitive meaning,
but it involves this thing--
some velocity vector for w--
and the velocity
vector for v. So this
is some relation on this
vector and these two vectors.
It's actually a very
intuitive relation.
Let me tell you what it means.
Basically, we want
to understand how
this length changes
to the first order.
So this guy's moving to first
order in this direction.
In fact, it's moving
on some curve,
and the initial tangent
is that direction.
And to understand how that
motion changes this edge
length, turns out
the right thing
to do is to project this
vector onto this one.
Makes sense.
So as this guy moves
in that direction,
This is the first-order change.
This distance here is
the first-order change
of this length as caused
by this vertex moving.
OK, that projected length
is actually very simple.
This is again, some
linear algebra stuff
interpreted geometrically.
This is a dot
product in d of w--
that vector-- dot product
with C of v minus C of w.
It turns out dot product
corresponds to projection.
So I'm taking this vector.
I'm projecting onto this one.
That's how you'd write
it algebraically.
And same deal over here.
If I project this
vector onto this one,
that's going to be the
first-order change to this edge
length caused by this vertex
moving in that direction.
So this is d of v dot
C of v, minus C of w.
So if I want this
edge length not
to change at all
to the first order,
then this projected length
should equal this projected
length.
And that's why I
drew it this way.
So it turns out this is a valid
motion, because that projected
length equals that one.
And in general, we want this
thing to equal that thing.
And if you rearrange
terms, that's
the same thing as this property.
I just take this one minus this
one, and set it equal to zero,
and you get that.
OK, so this is some intuition.
Maybe it makes sense, maybe not.
In the end, this is
all I care about.
And it's useful to
realize that it's
a first derivative of a motion,
because what that implies
is that if there's
a motion-- a real,
honest to goodness
motion-- then there's
an infinitesimal motion.
I'm going to abbreviate
that "inf motion."
Infinitesimal is pretty long.
Infinitesimal means
smaller-- very tiny-- smaller
than anything, I think
is the literal meaning.
So this is useful to us,
because the contrapositive
says if a linkage is
infinitesimally rigid-- which
just means if there is no
infinitesimal motion-- then
it's rigid.
So these are the
same statements.
This you prove just
by taking a motion
and taking its derivative.
This is identical to that.
So this is useful
because if we can ever
find something and show that
it's infinitesimally rigid,
then we've determined
that it's rigid.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
dot product [INAUDIBLE]
at a left right turn is
0, or that the terms are
at 90 degrees to each other?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this
dot product basically
means these two vectors are
at 90 degrees to each other.
That's another
geometric meaning.
I don't have a
geometric picture.
Maybe there is one,
but I have trouble
thinking about d
of v minus d of w.
That's not an intuitive thing
to me, but it's something.
And we're saying that
that vector should
be perpendicular to
C of v minus C of w.
However you want
to think about, I
like to think about it this
way, but they're equivalent.
All right, so how do we
tell whether something's
infinitesimally rigid?
Because somehow
that's useful to us.
Well, there's a
saying that everything
is linear to the first
order-- sort of a tautology.
And all you need to observe
is that this constraint
is linear in what we don't know.
So I want to know is there
some set of velocity vectors
d of v, and d of w,
for all the vertices,
so that these constraints hold.
But I already know C of
v, and I know C of w.
This is just where are
these vertices currently.
And I want to know can
I get started moving?
So these are my
known quantities,
and these are my
unknown quantities.
This is just some linear thing.
And the dot product-- I mean,
this is all just constant.
I know what they are.
So this is a linear equation.
The fancy way to write this
is as a matrix equation,
if you want.
So this is the idea
of a rigidity matrix.
So we have a whole bunch
of these constraints,
one for every edge.
And whenever you have a
bunch of linear constraints,
you can write them as
R-- some big matrix--
times the velocity, or
call them d's equals 0.
So I can absorb
this into a matrix.
If you're used to that, great.
Otherwise, this is
what it looks like.
My matrix R is going
to have a row that
has a whole bunch of zeroes.
And then at some point, it
has basically various versions
of this vector.
But because this
is one equation,
but in two dimensions, there's
two parts to all these vectors.
Two dimensions that'll
look something like this--
why did I change the order?
I think it's right.
OK, this is not very amazing.
It's just there are going
to be four terms in two
dimensions in this
equation, because we've
got d of v times this vector.
So there's a
x-coordinate vector,
and the y-coordinate
vector, and in d dimensions,
there will be d of them.
Here in two dimensions, I've got
the x-coordinate of the vector,
and the y-coordinate
of the vector.
So this will end up getting
multiplied on the right hand
side by d of v.
So the two v rows,
and this part will end up
getting multiplied by d of w.
yes, so these guys
switched around.
It's now w minus v in order
to implement that minus sign.
So whatever-- the point
is you get a matrix.
And what we care about, what
we're trying to solve for,
is d.
We know this entire
matrix, because we know c.
We know the configuration.
We just want to know is there
some set of velocity vectors
such that the rigidity matrix
times this is equal to zero?
This is called the set
of d's i for which this
is possible is called
the-- anyone know?
Good old linear
algebra-- it's called
the null space of
this rigidity--
null referring to
that 0, or the kernel.
So the set of all
infinitesimal motions
is the null space of
that matrix, also known
as the kernel of the matrix.
And so what?
Well this lets us use a bunch
of theorems in linear algebra.
So one fun fact is
that the dimension
of this space-- the space of
all infinitesimal motions--
seems like a useful
thing to know.
We want to know how
many-- this is basically
the number of degrees of freedom
in infinitesimal land, which
is not quite reality,
but it's close.
This is called the
nullity of the matrix.
That's just the
definition, but there's
a fun theorem called
the rank nullity
theorem from linear algebra.
Which says if you
have a matrix, you
take its rank-- which is
another quantity-- you take
its nullity, and you
add them together,
it will be the number of
columns in your matrix.
Now in our case, the number
of columns is d times n.
We have n vertices down
here, and each of them
has d coordinates.
So for us, this is d times n.
So this is like a
conserved quantity.
What we care about
is the nullity.
This is the space of motions--
infinitesimal motions.
And so consequently, we
care about this thing
called the rank.
And if you've ever seen
linear algebra, especially
linear algebra algorithms,
the bread and butter business
is computing the
rank of a matrix.
This can be done
in polynomial time.
So this is good news.
And intuitively what
it corresponds to
is the number of useful edges.
And this thing is the number
of degrees of freedom.
So it turns out these will
always be equal to d times n
in summation.
And what we care about,
infinitesimal rigidity,
means that-- or let's say
it's infinitesimally rigid if
and only if the
nullity of the matrix
is the space of rigid motions,
which I have to look up.
In general, in d dimensions,
it's this-- d plus 1 choose 2.
In two dimensions, there's
three rigid motions.
You've got the two
translations and the rotation.
Those we're not getting rid of.
They still exist in
infinitesimal land.
So in two dimensions,
ideally your nullity
is-- if you want rigidity,
your nullity should be 3.
And what this is telling us
is then the rank of the matrix
should be d n minus that.
In two dimensions,
that is 2n minus 3.
So this is telling us
something we already
knew, but essentially for
free, which is kind of fun,
if you know all
this linear algebra.
Which admittedly, even if you've
learned linear algebra, that
may not be the first thing you
care about in that context,
but for rigidity, this
is a really useful way
of thinking about things.
You've got all these
columns-- d times n of them.
You want to obliterate all the
degrees of freedom you can,
and leave just three of
them in two dimensions--
d times d plus 1 over
2 in d dimensions,
and you do that by
adding useful edges.
And useful edges here means
that the rank is high,
which essentially means none
of the rows in this matrix
cancel out with each other.
So it's another way of
thinking about essentially
everything we've seen.
And if you know linear
algebra, it's useful.
Otherwise, I'll tell
you how we can use it.
OK, one mathematical
thing we can do
is give another definition
of a generic point set.
Last class we talked
about one definition
of generic, which
was that you forbid
all non-trivial polynomial or
algebraic rational equations
on your points, which is very
messy and infinite and hard
to think about.
This definition will
be easy to think about
if you're used to
linear algebra.
So for some, it's
an improvement.
For others, it might be
the reverse-- whatever.
But at least this definition
is finite, which I like.
OK, for this definition we
need the notion of a minor.
So we have some matrix.
Actually, our matrices
are pretty rectangular.
And I just choose, let's say
k columns from the matrix--
let's say 3, and
I choose k rows--
the same number of
rows and columns.
I look at those elements
in the intersection.
That's a square matrix.
That's a minor-- that
3 by 3 square submatrix
is called a minor.
So there's a whole
bunch of minors,
but it's only finitely many.
It's exponential.
It's not easy to check.
You take all the minors
of your rigidity matrix.
And here I'm imagining
the complete graph,
so there's tons of edges.
There's n choose two edges.
So this'll be
independent linkage.
You could do it
specific to the linkage,
but it's better to do it
for the complete graph.
Then we take the
determinant of that matrix,
which I won't define.
It's a number associated
with that matrix.
And if it's non-zero--
now remember,
rigidity matrix is
defined as a function
of C. It depends where
you put the vertices.
So what I'm saying is if it's
non-zero for some choice of C,
then it should be non-zero
for this choice of C.
And if you find
such a configuration
C-- or I guess we call
this a realization C--
then that C is generic.
So if I gave you a
specific configuration,
you could, in principle,
in finite time-- it
won't be efficient-- you could
check all of these things.
And say, oh, I compute
out, I work out
what the determinant of that
submatrix is, that minor.
It's some algebraic function.
If it doesn't
cancel out entirely,
if it's not zero trivially,
it's not zero always,
then I just evaluate it
at this configuration.
And if it's non-zero
there, good.
That's generic.
So it's not useful
in a computable way,
but it's a definition.
It's a little bit nicer.
And now there's a
bunch of fun facts
about infinitesimal
motions and rigidity,
and the relation to
the generic case.
So there as we have
before, this definition
is not quite the same,
but it's effectively
the same as the last one.
Almost every
configuration is generic.
So maybe I should say
realization-- whatever.
I take some point set--
I take some vertex set.
I assign random
points to each vertex.
Then with probability
1, it will be generic
according to this definition.
That's really obvious if
you know linear algebra.
That's a good thing.
But here's what's
really cool-- if we
take any of these
generic configurations--
so just fix one--
rigidity is the same thing
as infinitesimal rigidity,
is the same thing
as generic rigidity
from last class.
Wow, this is cool,
because if I care
about any one of
these three things,
I just have to pick my
favorite generic point, which
I can do randomly.
I can just take a
random point, and if I
can evaluate any one
of these three things,
I learn about all the others.
So if you want to tell whether
a 3D graph is generically rigid,
you take a random
realization in 3D.
You compute the rank of
this matrix generalized
to the 3D case.
You see is it 3 n minus
6, and that will tell you
whether that generic realization
is infinitesimally rigid.
And if you chose it right, which
you will do at probability 1,
then that will tell you whether
the graph is generically rigid.
So when I said last class
generic rigidity in 3D is hard,
it's hard in the sense we don't
have a deterministic algorithm,
but randomized-- super easy.
Choose a random
configuration, check
the rank of the
rigidity matrix-- done.
So that's kind of cool.
And that's why this
infinitesimal rigidity stuff
is so important, because
it's so easy algorithmically.
Things become a lot easier.
Let me draw you one
example just to show
what happens at
non-generic points.
I've actually drawn
this example before.
So here's a non-generic point.
These three points
are collinear.
And you can work out
there is some minor
that is 0, but shouldn't be.
And this thing is rigid, because
we have rigid triangle here.
We have a rigid triangle here.
So these two points are
pinned relative to each other.
And then this thing is
taut, so it can't move.
But to the first
order, it can move.
And it's allowed to move
straight up or down--
anything perpendicular
to this segment.
That's always true.
If you take a segment, and
you move one vertex but not
the other perpendicular
to the segment,
that's a valid
infinitesimal motion.
Why?
Because if I project this
onto the segment, I get 0.
So this length is not
changing to the first order.
And this is really necessary.
To the first order, you can't
really distinguish this guy
actually moving up,
and therefore getting
slightly longer versus this guy
moving along a circle centered
at that point, which
is a valid motion.
To the first order,
they look the same,
because you're going straight
up or down in first derivative.
OK, here, to the
first order, you
can't realize the
fact that if you're
going to go on this
circle and you're
going to go on this circle,
you get a contradiction.
But it's pretty accurate.
And if you perturb this
example, infinitesimal rigidity
will give you the right answer.
This is an example where
infinitesimal rigidity is
a little bit weaker than--
no, infinitesimal flexibility
having infinitesimal motion
is a little weaker than having
a motion, but the reverse holds.
If there's a motion, there's
always an infinitesimal motion.
If you're infinitesimally
rigid, you're always rigid.
That example is rigid, but
not infinitesimally rigid,
so it's sort of strict.
OK so far?
That's the more technical
part of the lecture.
Question?
STUDENT: Will [INAUDIBLE]
be square matricies?
PROFESSOR: The rigidity matrices
are almost never square.
Good question.
The minors are
going to be square,
because we told them to be.
But I think typically,
in the ideal setting,
we're going to
have d n columns--
so let's say 2 times n
columns in two dimensions.
And we're supposed to
have 2n minus 3 rows.
So it's close, but
in general, they
should differ by
about this much.
So they're almost
square, actually.
Glad you asked.
STUDENT: You can
add [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You could
always add extra edges
and make it square, yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
So that's another good question.
What happens if I add
more edges than this many?
The rank just won't go up.
Any edges you add will
add redundant constraints,
and so the rank can never
go above this value.
You need at least this
many edges to get there,
and we know we can get
there with that many edges,
but only in the
minimal rigid case.
You could add more edges.
You could make it a
super-tall matrix if you want,
but you're not going
to increase the rank.
All right, let's use this
for something more fun.
So maybe go over here.
I don't need the
rigidity matrix any more.
Tensegrity-- so this
is in some sense
an extension of rigidity
theory to a whole other theory
called tensegrity theory.
The word tensegrity comes from
tensional integrity, which
is a very Buckminster Fuller
term, and he invented it.
I don't think he
invented tensegrities,
but he invented the word.
And they are things
like this-- here's
a tensegrity built and
given to me by Bob Connolly.
And it has well,
I guess, there are
three kinds of edges physically.
There are the springs.
There are these struts, and
there are these wire cables.
And its rigid.
It's a little flexible,
just because the springs
aren't perfectly stiff,
like all springs.
But there are three
kinds of edges here,
and we're going to model
the three kinds of edges.
The edges that
we've modeled so far
are most closely related
to these springs,
so that's not quite the
right physical analogy.
What I would call the
edges and linkages is bars.
Bars are, like,
solid attachments,
like steel rods
that are permanently
attached to the two endpoints.
The lengths of these
edges should never change.
That's been the world
we live in, at least
to the first order, whatever.
Edge lengths of bars
should never change.
Now we have these cables.
Now cables really
can get shorter.
This cable is perfectly
happy to get shorter.
I can pull those two
vertices together.
But what it prevents
is getting longer.
If I pull-- you
can't tell, but I'm
pulling really hard on
these vertices apart.
Nothing happens, because this
cable can't get any longer.
So cables prevent
extension, but they do not
prevent compression.
Struts, on the other hand--
they prevent compression.
If I push on these two vertices,
they don't get any closer.
If I pull, it comes right out.
And you have to realize
that these are eye hooks,
and so really, those
could come apart.
All these struts are
preventing is compression.
They don't prevent expansion.
So that's the thing
we want to model.
This is a tensegrity.
It's a generalization
of a linkage
and where we allow
three kinds of edges.
It can be a bar-- and
this is the old case,
which is that the
length is fixed.
We can have cables, which
is the length can decrease,
but it can't increase.
And there are struts,
which are the reverse--
you can increase
but not decrease.
Seems like a useful
generalization,
especially because
people build things
they actually use
struts and cables.
Like you look at most bridges--
tons of cables around.
I think I have an example here.
There's this guy,
Ken Snelson, who
makes a whole bunch of
cool tensegrity sculptures.
This is a particularly
tall one in Washington, DC
that I saw a couple years ago.
That's to give you
an idea of height.
And there's this
really cool view
if you stand-- here's a person.
You stand in the
center, and you look up.
It has this really
cool, sixfold rotational
reflectional symmetry.
I could stare at this for hours.
I think that's just
the [? zoom ?].
So we want to understand
those structures.
This one's also
rigid, hopefully.
It's been standing for 40 years.
So what can we define in
this generalized setting
of tensegrity?
We want motions.
We want rigidity.
We want generic rigidity.
We want infinitesimal rigidity.
All the good things
we've defined,
hopefully, carry over to this.
Well, all but one of
them carry over to this.
OK, we can define a
configuration space.
It's going to be a little
smaller, or a little different
from our old
configuration space.
It's a space of all possible
configurations where
these three things
hold-- give you
desired lengths for
each of these things.
As long as these
constraints hold,
that the lengths stay the
same here, get smaller
here or the same, or stay
the same or get larger here--
that's a valid configuration.
So it's actually a slightly
larger configuration space
than what we had.
A path through
that space is going
to be a motion,
just like before.
Configuration is just
a bunch of points
where this holds--
blah, blah, blah.
The problem is, there's no
notion of generic rigidity.
For example, this is a
generically flexible linkage.
We all know it.
Now I take my yellow
chalk and add struts.
Maybe I'll put some arrows on
it to make it more obvious.
These are things they can
expand, but cannot contract.
Then this configuration
is rigid or flexible?
Flexible, yeah-- this is a
one degree of freedom linkage.
The white part is a one
degree of freedom linkage,
and if you move this thing
in a particular direction,
indeed, this increases
and that increases.
Check it.
This one is rigid.
The only way to move
the square-- or in fact,
any generic convex
configuration--
is one of these pairs
has to get shorter.
The other one will get
longer, but one of them
will get shorter.
So this is the same graph,
and the same labeling
of which edges are bars
and which are struts,
but in one configuration
it's flexible.
The other it's rigid.
So we lose generic rigidity.
But infinitesimal
rigidity still works,
and generic configurations
are still meaningful.
It's just that they're
not all the same.
There's not, in this
case, for four vertices,
there's two kinds of
generic configurations.
So it makes life
a little harder.
But let's say this
part will work well.
So why don't I be
clever, erase this part.
So this is the idea of
an infinitesimal motion.
of a tensegrity.
Well, I want to take
the same dot product,
and I claim this is really
measuring-- it's a number,
and it's measuring the sign's
change in length of that edge.
So if C of v minus
C of w dot product
with d of v minus d of w is
greater than or equal to 0,
that's the property
I want for struts.
That says it gets
longer or stays
the same to the first order.
Now of course, in reality it
might get slightly shorter,
but not in the first derivative.
And it should be less than
or equal to 0 for cables,
and should be equal
to 0 for bars.
So that's the new notion
of infinitesimal motion.
Now, this is no longer a linear
system of linear equations.
I can no longer write this as a
matrix times a vector equals 0.
But this is this
more general thing
called a linear program,
where I have linear equations.
I also have linear inequalities.
So in fact, I can write it
as some other matrix R prime.
Actually, it's the same matrix.
R prime times d is greater
than or equal to 0.
This is the general form
of a linear program.
And you can write an equality
constraint in this world
just by taking it
and its negation,
setting both of them
greater or equal to 0.
That forces them to
be equal to zero.
All you need to know
is it there are fast
algorithms to solve this, also.
So if I give you a tensegrity
in polynomial time,
you can tell whether there is a
valid infinitesimal motion that
does all things you want on
the struts, cables, and bars.
Cool, questions?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This R--
this is some matrix,
and this is your
vector of all the d's.
STUDENT: Right.
And saying that it's greater
than or equal to 0 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, that means
element lines, sorry.
You take a matrix
times a vector.
You get a big vector.
This is a vector of zeroes.
I should have said that.
And it's just saying every
element in the vector
is greater than
or equal to zero.
So it's just a fancy way of
rewriting this stuff again.
But this is what we
call linear programs,
and that's what's solvable.
STUDENT: And that's
just for struts, then?
PROFESSOR: Well, for
cables you could just
negate the left-hand side.
And then that's greater
than or equal to zero.
For bars you have to include
the same left-hand side
and its negation.
Yeah, I'm skipping some steps.
That's why I had
to write R prime--
it changes a little bit.
How many people know
about linear programming?
OK, about 2/3, so for
you guys, you also
know that there's this thing
called linear programming
duality.
If you have a linear program,
the first thing everyone
should do when they have a
linear program is take the dual
and see what you get.
I'm just going to
tell you what you get.
But that's the next
trick I want to pull.
So dual notion-- essentially
what prevents you
from solving that system--
in other words, what
makes something
rigid-- is something
called equilibrium stress.
So stress, for me,
is just a real number
assigned to every edge.
And here I'm going
to use the word
edge to mean bar,
strut, or cable.
So a real number s
of e for each edge e,
and have to have
three properties.
If I have a cable, then that
number should be non-negative.
If I have a strut, it
should be non-positive.
If I have a bar, I don't care--
could be positive, or negative,
or zero.
And then there's the
equilibrium condition,
which is that if I take the
sum over all vertices w, where
v w is an edge,
the weighted vector
C of v minus C of
w-- so I forgot
to mention we're
assuming we have
some configuration
of our tensegrity.
This is the zero
vector for all vertices
v. Let me draw a picture.
I'll draw a real
example, how's that?
Here's a rigid linkage.
I'm not going to say yet which
edges are struts and cables.
In some sense, I
can do that later.
And I'm going to put numbers
1 along all the outside edges
and the numbers 3 along all
the inside edges-- sorry,
negative 1 and positive 3.
And then if you work
out what this is saying,
I'm taking the
vectors-- so I'm looking
at each vertex like this
one, and saying OK, well, I
take all of the
incoming, whatever.
Let's think of all the edges
incident to that vertex.
I weight them by this number.
In this case, they're
all multiplied by 3.
So I take this vector.
I multiply it by 3.
It gets three times as long.
Take this vector, multiply by
3, this vector multiplied by 3.
I add them up.
I should get the zero vector.
And if this is really
an equilateral triangle,
I will get the zero
vector, so that's good.
And I'm going to
draw arrows here
to signify what this
means intuitively
is that this edge is pushing
with a really big arrow.
This is an arrowhead of size 3.
Try to draw it to scale.
Then, of course,
this vertex will not
move subject to those forces.
These forces balance out.
On the other hand,
this guy, I have
these edges of
weight negative 1.
That means it's going
to pull, and it's
going to pull with the
arrowhead of size 1.
OK, and I claim also that
these vertices do not
move subject to
those three forces.
How do you check that?
The proper way to
check it is to draw
what's called a force polygon.
Those who have done structural
engineering know this.
So I take, let's see, there's
this vector, which is length
3 times that, so it would
be something like that long.
And let's say I'm pushing in
that direction, so I go there.
Then I follow this thing
with the weight of 1,
but in sort of the
opposite direction,
so it will be like this.
This is my attempt at
copying that edge length
and getting what I want.
And then the other
force is this one.
It doesn't actually matter
which order I do these in.
And if I end up back
where I started,
that means the total
force is 0 as a vector,
and so this vertex
is stationary.
That's the force polygon.
So you can just check this.
It's a geometric
condition, if you will,
that each vertex is stationary.
That is the notion of
being in equilibrium.
And this is just the
algebra to write that down.
Now what the heck does this
thing mean intuitively?
If your tensegrity
is going to be rigid,
somehow the edges
can prevent a motion.
And intuitively,
what that means--
I'm going to say this right--
so this is like an edge pushing
really hard away from
itself, against the vertices.
That's like a strut.
A strut prevents compression.
So that the force that it
can actuate effectively
is an outward force.
Whereas cables
prevent extension,
so they can sort of
pull back, say, no,
you can't get any longer.
I'm going to pull towards me.
So this is like a cable.
This is like a strut.
Now bars can do both.
That's why there's no
constraint on bars.
But assuming I've got
this right-- and I didn't.
I got it backwards.
Minus 3 plus 1-- it's
symmetric so it doesn't matter
in some sense, but the intuition
matches when cables can pull,
and struts can push,
and bars can do both,
because they prevent
motion in both directions.
All right, now, it would be
nice to say you're rigid if
and only if you have
an equilibrium stress.
But that's not true.
Let me tell you what is true.
So this is duality.
This goes back to Roth and
Whiteley, 1981-- good year.
So let's see,
here's what's true--
if I look at all the
equilibrium stresses,
and I find some stress
that is non-zero
on a particular structure
or cable-- I should mention
there's always a
trivial stress, which
is you set all of
these S's to zero.
Then everything will hold.
So what we're interested
in are nontrivial stresses,
where you're nonzero somewhere,
and the interesting case
is when you're nonzero on some
strut or cable, let's say.
So if there is such
an equilibrium stress,
then it's not quite the
case that you're rigid,
but you're rigid on that edge.
Every infinitesimal motion holds
the length of that edge fixed.
So this is a strut or a cable.
It could get longer or
it could get smaller,
depending which case we're in.
But if there's a stress that's
nonzero on that edge, then
in fact, it can't
change length at all.
It effectively acts like a
bar in this configuration.
That's what this theorem says.
And these are equivalent.
If you want to
know can I possibly
make the strut any longer?
You just see can I find
an equilibrium stress
for that thing that's non-zero?
Another thing you can say--
almost equivalent to this
or a consequence of that--
if I have some tensegrity,
and I want to know is it
infinitesimally rigid,
that is the case if and
only if two conditions hold.
One is that every strut
or cable is nonzero
in some stress-- in some
equilibrium stress--
and I'll say the corresponding
linkage is rigid.
So all this is saying is if
you can find a stress that
is nonzero on every
particular strut or cable,
then all of those things
are effectively bars.
So you can convert your
tensegrity into a linkage
where all the edges are bars.
And then it's just
a matter of testing
rigidity or infinitesimal
rigidity of that linkage, which
is something we
already know how to do.
So in some sense, we already
know how to do all of this,
because this is just
a linear program.
We can solve it.
But this is a more intuitive
way of proving this.
If you want to prove to
someone that tensegrity
is infinitesimally rigid, you
give them a bunch of stresses,
one for each strut
or cable, or maybe
you just need one stress
to hit all of them.
And then you show that the
linkage is infinitesimally
rigid, which you
could do by computing
the rank of the rigidity matrix.
Strut can have zero
stress-- the weight is zero.
OK, let's keep going.
Lots of a cool things to
talk about, maybe over here.
I want to do a little
diversion for fun,
something called
spider webs, like this.
You might have seen them before.
A spiderweb is something
where every edge is basically
a cable.
You can see under
wind and tension,
they get a little bit shorter
than they're supposed to be.
But they can't
really get longer.
They are pretty strong
at preventing expansion.
So a spiderweb is
something that can
be stressed with all
positive weights.
And the reason it holds
in tension-- positive,
yeah, cables-- all of the edges
can have a positive stress,
and it will be in equilibrium.
And in spiderwebs, in
fact, this is the same--
these two-- rigidity
and positive stresses
are the same thing.
This is sort of a special
case, and Connolly
studied these in 1982.
There's some special
points in a spiderweb.
Here they're kind
of off the page.
There's a point down here
where it attaches to something,
and up there, and up there.
Those guys do not
satisfy equilibrium,
or you can say those edges
have some negative stresses.
Or another way to
think of it is there's
a point off to infinity,
which is how this is drawn,
and you can have
a positive stress.
And at infinity, you don't
have to satisfy equilibrium.
So there's a little something
special at the boundary,
but everywhere else-- interior
and all these vertices
in here-- you have equilibrium,
and all the stresses
are positive.
And it turns out in
this case, you're
automatically
infinitesimally rigid.
That tensegrity is
Normally, we need to
also check the underlying
linkage is rigid, but for
spiderwebs, you don't have to.
Why do I care about spiderwebs?
Because they give us something
called origami tesselations.
This is a brand-new
result from this summer
at [? OSMI ?] by Robert
Lang and Alex Bateman.
Here's a little example of an
origami tessellation, this fold
by Jenny [? Ramsier ?],
just the one
I had hanging
around in my office.
It looks a little
cooler that way.
Let me hold it up to the light.
I can see it great.
You don't see the light.
It looks pretty cool.
It's folded from
one square, and it's
folded in some sense
with a regular pattern.
You can see regular
hexagons, hexagonal pattern.
And these guys have been around
for a long time, probably
at least the '60s,
maybe earlier--
a lot of Japanese artists,
lot of American artists.
And there's been a
lot of excitement
about origami tesselations
since the mid '90s.
I think Chris Palmer revitalized
them, and then tons of people
are looking at them.
And there's this cool
algorithm for building them.
So you take some tessellation
like these squares,
and triangles, and hexagons--
some collection of polygons.
You shrink all of
them a little bit,
but all by the same amount.
And then you twist them a
little bit, all the same amount.
So here they are twisted.
And then you just
connect the dots.
So these two edges used to
be joined to each other.
So I'm going to connect these
guys, and connect these guys.
That's the green edges.
And that's your crease pattern.
You erase the red stuff, and
you get your crease pattern,
and you fold it, and you get
this cool tessellation-- magic.
Now the question is,
when does this work?
This algorithm has been around
forever, as far as I know.
I don't know exactly how old
it is, or who invented it,
but it's pretty natural.
It's how most
tesselations are folded.
But when does it work?
And there is a brand-new
result from the summer
that it works for some
choice of those angles.
So I had some flexibility--
how much do I shrink
and how much do I turn?
But this will work for
some choice of turn
and shrink amount, if
and only if your graph
or your initial
tessellation is a spiderweb.
Pretty cool-- spiderwebs
have this neat property
that you can do the shrink and
twist tessellation algorithm,
and it works.
And here is an example of
that-- a spiderweb, so to speak,
but drawn visually.
And this is actually a proof
that-- these are basically
all the force polygons
showing that you
can get a positive
equilibrium stress.
And you turn it into a
crease pattern, fold it flat,
and it works.
This is, of course,
in simulation,
but you can really fold
these things, and they work.
So that's kind of fun--
a little bit origami out
of linkages and tensegrities.
Questions?
All right, then we move on.
I want to tell you one more
cool thing about stresses
and tensegrities-- yet another
characterization of stresses,
which is polyhedral liftings.
A polyhedral lifting
is going to work
if I have a non-crossing
configuration.
So I don't want
to have this-- two
edges that cross each other.
I only want to have
pictures like this,
where edges don't
cross each other.
They only share endpoints.
Then I can define what's
called a polyhedral lifting.
So this is a
planograph, if you will.
Polyhedral lifting
is going to be
an assignment of
z-coordinates to the vertices.
So it's going to be
a z-coordinate z of v
for each vertex v such that
each face remains planar.
Because I forbid
crossings, I end up
decomposing space-- the
plane here-- this only works
in two dimensions.
This is one thing that
does not generalize
to arbitrary dimension.
So I get a bunch
of triangles here.
And so I want to lift.
I want to assign
some z-coordinate
to each of these vertices, such
that each of these triangles
remains planar.
Well, actually,
that always holds.
Triangles are always planar.
But there's another face, which
is the outside face out here.
That's a quadrilateral.
That one also has
to remain planar.
So these four vertices have
to be lifted onto some plane.
This guy can be
lifted however it
wants in this
particular picture.
In general, you're going to
have a lot of non-triangles.
Those should all remain planar.
That's a lifting.
One thing you can do--
there's some freedom here.
If you have any lifting
or, for example,
you could not lift them at all.
Set all the
z-coordinates to zero.
That's fine.
You could also just
lift everything
onto some other
plane, and generally
have a rigid motion of freedom.
You can't translate
around, but you
have one two-degree
two-rotational freedoms,
I think.
And so we would just
like to get rid of those.
So say remove rigid motions
by forcing the outside face
to lie in z equals 0.
So let's say these
guys all stay at 0.
So in this particular
example, this guy
can go to any value, positive
or negative, but that's it.
Now, this is a lot like
stresses-- in fact,
it's identical to stresses.
It's probably not
obvious, but just
like stresses where you
could set everything to 0,
here you can also
set everything to 0.
It's not a big connection,
but it turns out
they really are
the same thing for
non-crossing configurations.
This is called
Maxwell-Cremona Theorem.
This is probably one
of the oldest theorems
we will cover here--
I guess anywhere.
Well, it's not that old-- 1864.
That might be the oldest.
Maxwell proved this,
or claimed it in 1864.
Theorem is there's a
one-to-one correspondence
between the equilibrium stresses
and polyhedral liftings.
And fun fact-- negative
stresses correspond to valleys.
So valley is
something like this.
You know what valleys are, but
it's maybe a little bit subtle.
We're not folding
all the way here,
so this would also be
considered a valley,
because it has sort of
negative dihedral triangle.
It's really hard to see.
What I meant was
something like this.
That's a valley edge here.
This is another valley
edge here-- whatever.
A positive stress
corresponds to a mountain,
which is the same
picture upside down.
A zero stress corresponds
to a flat angle--
doesn't have to be horizontal,
but it has to be flat.
So it could be like this.
I'm going to need this in a
moment proving the next thing.
I'm not going to
prove this theorem,
but it would be fun to
actually see it in action.
I've never seen it implemented,
so another fun project.
I give you tensegrity.
You compute an
equilibrium stress, which
is easy to do by linear
programming, and draw-- you
can directly construct
from that the 3D lifting,
which would be kind of cool.
I'm going to use
basically everything I
proved today to
prove a big theorem--
the Carpenter's Rule Theorem.
It's why I'm wearing
this t-shirt that
has nothing to do with the
Carpenter's Rule Theorem.
And it's about
non-crossing linkages.
So this is the beginning.
So far we've been
allowing crossings,
except for this
very last theorem.
Now we begin this section
where I forbid crossings
between the edges, just
like what that picture was.
Prevent this, and this is a
constraint on the configuration
space now.
I'm going to look at
all the configurations
where no two edges cross.
This is a smaller version of
our old configuration space.
I'm not going to
define it formally.
It's a bit messy.
It's not too nasty.
It's still defined by
polynomial inequalities.
Question?
STUDENT: What if you have
one of those diagonals
and switch it to be in relation
to each other [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You want
this picture and--
STUDENT: Either one.
PROFESSOR: And you
want to add this?
Or-- that's crossing--
not allowed.
Whatever you're
saying is not allowed.
That's the easy answer.
I don't quite know what
it is, but what we allow--
and in this case
I'm just thinking
about linkages for the moment.
It's just you can hinge
at common vertices.
Two edges either
share a vertex or not.
And that's it.
But they're not allowed
to touch anywhere else.
And now what we care
about is something
called a locked linkage.
And a linkage is locked
if its configuration
space is disconnected.
So the configuration space
would look something like this.
Maybe it has three components.
If I have some
configuration here,
I can move to any other
and same over here,
but there's no way
to get from this configuration
to that configuration.
They're disconnected
from each other.
So this would be
kind of sad news
if you're looking for motions.
It means you cannot get from
everywhere to everywhere.
There are some locked
configurations that cannot get
back to start.
However you define start
and locked doesn't matter,
but the linkage is locked when
there's two things that cannot
reach each other.
And the Carpenter's Rule Theorem
is about one case of that.
So this was essentially
my Ph.D. thesis,
so paper in 2000 by Bob Connolly
who made that tensegrity,
[? Gunta ?] [? Rota ?] and me.
And it says that if
we have a linkage,
and say we take a configuration
of that linkage, and let's
say it's of maximum degree
2, so every vertex has
at most two edges
coming out of it.
Then there's a motion of that
linkage that straightens out--
so if you have maximum
degree 2, you have paths,
and you might have some cycles.
You might have many of them.
And it's going to
straighten all the paths
and convexify all the cycles.
And it's also expansive.
But before I get to
that, this is essentially
showing that these
configuration's bases
are connected.
It doesn't quite imply it
the way I've worded it.
But for example, for
paths, I take some path.
I want to know, can I get
from this configuration
to some other configuration?
Well, I could take
this one, find
a motion that
straightens the chain.
I could take this
one, find a motion
that straightens the chain.
So here I've drawn it straight.
I take this motion.
I apply it forwards.
I apply it backwards, and
I get from here to here.
So if I can straighten
all the paths,
I can definitely get from
anywhere to anywhere.
For convex cycles, it's
a little less obvious,
but it's also true.
There's one catch which
I didn't say here.
I need to add outermost.
When you have nesting like
this, you're in trouble.
This guy is not going
to get straightened out.
It could be super long.
It may not have room
to straighten out
inside that convex chamber.
So these guys will come
along for the ride,
but they won't actually
get straightened.
The outermost guys will get
straightened and convexified.
The other fun
property-- and this
is how we actually
proved the theorem--
so this was open
for a long time.
People thought this was true.
And the key to proving it is
by making the theorem stronger,
which is that all pairwise
distances between vertices
increase or stay the same.
Some of them have to stay the
same, because they're edges.
They are bars in there.
They can't change in length.
But everything
else will increase.
Now there's a couple
reasons why this is useful.
One is that it says you don't
have to worry about crossings.
If I have some edges that
initially don't cross,
and I'm worried
about them crossing,
that can't happen
if you're expansive.
If I say, well, this
distance has to increase,
and this distance
has to increase,
there's no way
that this vertex is
going to cross over that edge.
One of them would
have to get shorter.
So this essentially
says, everything's
flying away from each other.
So if initially
you're non-crossing,
you will be
non-crossing forever.
That really makes life
easier, because crossings
are hard to think about.
This lets you not
worry about crossings.
You just have to
worry about distances.
How do I worry about
distances increasing?
Tensegrities--
struts-- struts will
force things to be expansive.
If I want to model this
picture, all I need to do
is add a whole of struts.
Let's go over here.
So we're going to prove
this theorem in, like,
five minutes-- easy.
Once you build all this
technology, which was existing,
you can prove this
theorem, once you
realize this is the
theorem you want
to prove-- this expansiveness.
So what we're going to
do is build a tensegrity.
And it's going to have a bar
for every edge of the given
linkage.
So that's just the same
thing as we had given.
It's also going to have a
strut between every other pair
of vertices-- heck,
every pair of vertices.
It's kind of redundant
for the bars,
but every pair of vertices.
That says that all pairwise
distances must increase or stay
the same.
So this is a tensegrity.
What I want to prove is that
this tensegrity is flexible.
If I can prove that
it's always flexible--
well, until the end, which
is when everybody's straight
or convex-- all the
outermost guys are straight
or convex-- then I'll
have proved this theorem.
So while this theorem is
about actual connectivity
of configuration spaces,
it says paths and cycles
have connected
configuration spaces.
You get from everywhere
to everywhere.
It even gives you an
algorithm for doing
that, which we'll
talk about next class.
We use just, is this thing
rigid or flexible at all?
And that's the power of all this
rigidity stuff, just telling
whether something can
move a little bit,
and then just doing that
over and over again,
you will be able to find
that you can actually
go all the way, and get
to straight or convex.
But how do we actually
prove this thing?
So the point is, claim this
tensegrity is infinitesimally
flexible, meaning it is
not infinitesimally rigid.
And that will imply
that there's at least
an infinitesimal
expansive motion.
And then you have to use some
fancy tricks-- not fancy,
some tricks I don't
want to talk about.
You basically integrate
that vector field,
and that will give you an
actual expansive motion.
Let's not worry about that.
The interesting part is show
that at least infinitesimally,
this tensegrity
moves a little bit.
So what do know?
Duality-- if I want to
show not that it's rigid--
I want to show
that it's flexible.
But it's rigid if and only if
this is true and this is true.
This will actually
always be true--
the corresponding
linkage is rigid--
because I put in every
edge is in there.
If I turn them all into bars,
this thing's not moving at all.
So fact, this second condition
doesn't really matter.
What matters is the stresses.
If I want to show that
it's flexible, not rigid.
I want to show these
stresses don't exist.
Now stresses always exist.
I could set all the
stresses to be 0.
But I claim actually
pretty much all the
stresses have to be 0, at least
on the cables and the struts,
which is what I care about here.
They have to be 0.
So this will be implied
by every equilibrium
stress is 0 on all
struts and cables.
So you can never get
this thing to hold
for any of the struts
and the cables.
And therefore, in some sense,
none of them are fixed,
and therefore, you're
actually flexible.
That's implied by this
duality statement.
OK, stresses are a little
hard to think about.
I prefer to think about
polyhedral liftings, let's say.
OK, the key here is to plug
together all the right results.
This will be true if and only
if every polyhedron lifting
is flat.
So I guess in our
case, it will be 0,
because the outside face sets
all the z-coordinates to 0,
so everything else will
have to be in that plane.
So all the
z-coordinates will be 0.
So these are
equivalent statements.
All I need to prove is that
every polyhedral lifting
is flat.
So we're going to prove this
theorem by contradiction.
Suppose there was a
non-flat polyhedron lifting.
What could it look like?
Did I just erase what I wanted?
Probably.
Greater than or equal to
0 for cables, less than
or equal to 0 for struts.
That's the one I care about.
Who cares about cables?
All right, so this
is the stress.
And equilibrium stress
has to be less than
or equal to 0 for every strut.
Less than or equal
to 0 corresponds
to a valley edge or flat edge.
Now in this linkage, almost
all the edges are struts.
There's a few that
are bars, this,
like, little path is a bar.
Those could be
valleys or mountains.
We don't know.
But everything else has
to be a valley or flat.
For flat, we're good.
We're happy.
We want all the
edges to be flat.
So how could it be that almost
every edge in this picture
is a valley?
That seems a little tricky.
And we're going to
show it can't happen.
If everything's a
valley, something's
going to go wrong
at the top picture,
because you've got to have
mountains, like, turn around.
So let's look at the top.
Look at the maximum
z-coordinate.
Now this could actually look
like many different things,
but I'm going to consider one
case-- the easy case-- where
you have, in the
maximum z-coordinate,
you have one point.
And then around that,
everything descends.
OK, these are all the edges
incident to that point.
You form some kind of--
OK, so this is maximum z.
This is another plane.
I'm going to slice that, which
is maximum z minus epsilon--
slightly below the
maximum z-coordinate.
And in a sort of typical case,
we're going to get a polygon.
Now note that this polygon
has this nice property,
that wherever it has a convex
angle, you get a mountain here.
Wherever you have a reflex
angle, like this one,
you get a valley edge here.
You can see that
3-dimensional picture.
Every polygon has at least
three convex vertices.
That means there are at least
three mountains incident
to this maximum
z-coordinate But mountains
have to correspond
to positive stresses.
Positive stresses have
to correspond to bars,
because struts can't
carry positive stresses.
So that means you have
at least three bars
incident to that edge.
But I assumed I was maximum
degree 2-- contradiction.
Isn't that cool?
It's very easy when
you set it up right.
This works almost always, but
there is another situation
which can happen, which
is, like, you have--
in the maximum
z-coordinate you might
have a couple of
bars at the top.
That's a worry.
This is all in maximum z.
And so when you slice
below, you don't actually
get a whole polygon.
You might actually only
get something around here.
But again, you
can't get from here
to around there
without some mountain.
It's hard to even imagine,
because it can't happen.
But this is a mountain,
and this is a mountain,
and you want to somehow slope
a surface below this plane,
and get around to over here with
only valleys-- ain't happening.
You've got to have
another mountain in here.
And so that's the
general picture.
And the only thing
that can happen
is you actually prove that all
of this stuff has to be flat.
So that's the one
way it can happen.
You can't have strict valleys,
but you could have them all 0.
So in fact, the one case
where you can have stress
is when you have all of
this outside stuff flat.
And then inside you don't know.
I can prove, using
this generalized lemma,
that all of these
regions are locally flat.
And therefore, this whole
outside face has to be flat.
Therefore, I'm particular.
I can't have a reflex vertex,
because then this side
would have to all be flattened.
So then the whole
thing is flattened.
The only way the whole
thing can't be flat
is if your polygon is already
convex, and then we're done.
Also straight this can happen.
I think with straight,
you don't get any stress.
Here you can actually
have a lifting.
Actually, all these guys
would be below the plane,
because everything's a valley.
This would be like
an actual valley,
where you have a
village or whatever.
That can happen, but only when
the boundary of your valley
is convex.
And so that proves the theorem.
And that is the
Carpenter's Rule Theorem.
Next time, we're going to talk
about the other situations.
This was two dimensions,
and maximum degree 2.
We can think about what
happens with degree 3.
Then you can get locked things.
What happens in
three dimensions?
Then you can get locked things.
What happens in four dimensions?
Then you can't get locked
things, and other fun things
like that.
Oh, and why is it called the
Carpenter's Rule Theorem?
Because this is a
carpenter's rule.
And in a carpenter's rule,
actually, all the edge lengths
are the same.
But as far as we
know that doesn't
make this theorem
any easier to prove.
And also in the carpenter's
rule, you can have crossings,
but other than that, it's
just like a carpenter's rule.
So there you go.
So if you've never
played with one,
this is what people used
before flexible measuring tape.
They still use them a
lot in Europe, but not
so much in the US,
but you can still
buy them at the hardware store.
That's it.